well it feels good to be back on a
Monday night danny has been teaching
this class for a while but I joined the
Sinquefield Cup I had all these fans
here they said they're only going if I'm
teaching it so here I am stepping up you
gotta get the fans what they want so a
month or so ago back when I was teaching
the class weekly we've been going over
the winter where or or as Ben Simon very
aptly titled it the voracious ving over
and since I'm American I have social
permission to mispronounce it and call
it winter wear for the rest of this
lecture and today we're just going to be
focused on the main line winter which is
the poison pond so some of the sharpest
most aggressive ways that you could play
will flip the board around so to see it
from blacks point of view so just to
refresh we get the French defense and
after the two most logical moves when
white plays Knight to c3 the most
classical way to defend the e pawn black
now instead of Knight to f6 plays the
move Bishop to b4 and this is the winter
wear so okay for some of the sidelines
you can see part one but we're just
going to focus here on the main line
which is e five and in the French the
main break that black is usually playing
for he's trying to strike at the center
so c5 and white takes the opportunity to
grab the bishop pair okay so he gets the
bishop pair okay and we did cover this
last time but we'll go over one more
time if Bishop to a5 does anybody know
what tricky move white has here yeah b4
and so the point is after you take this
pin is temporarily blocked so now we can
use this time to jump in to some of
these dark squares are the arrows better
be working others well it's called Danny
again yeah before the show we had to
call Danny to set up chess base right
he's the he's the IT guru but uh
you want to go here pawn takes pawn
check okay I'll play here and then my
next move is just going to be you know I
might go here I might go here you're
going to get into some trouble
Bishop c7 okay very logical alright I'll
just go here Mikey seven okay and at
some point I think I just take this what
was the line there's a way to really get
you good how do I get you good Arjun
Arjun here so I need I need a lot of
arjun help what's the what's the get um
good line what I can get him good yes
okay so I mean it's just like it just
says white is up a tremendous amount and
this is actually interesting because the
theme that we're kind of going to see a
lot especially in the winter where every
opening kind of has their own sort of
spirit to it they owned the way that you
sort of play it sometimes it's very
positional but in the winter where I'll
call you in a second what tends to
matter more than material is the
activity of your pieces so the fact that
we're going to get control of some of
these dark squares I thought this was
maybe this is the move and even see what
the computer said but I think this is
actually the move so I'm attacking this
and okay you have to like you have to
play Bishop d6 or something and if I
want I can take and check or who knows
maybe I wanna keep my pieces here but
what tends to matter in the winter we're
and we're going to see this a lot will
back up to our our position here because
it is it is an interesting line and some
good people have indeed played the move
Bishop to a5 if it'll let me Bishop to
a5 in this position so some of the
people have played that way so it is
possible but in general in this opening
especially in the poison pawn that we're
going to see material doesn't matter
what matters is the activity of your
pieces so having just the better place
pieces or what is going to generate the
most counter play for you in these types
of positions and tonight we're going to
focus on the main line here and all
right there's kind of a lot of lines I
wanted to look at but we're just going
to look at the sharpest move here
there's moves like Knight f3 h4a for
there's a whole bunch of moves here but
for the sake of the the time here we're
just going to look at the main main line
here and so this is where we were going
to deviate from the last lecture we
showed a Cara Juana game from the US
Championship where his opponent Sam
Shanklin castled that was our last
lecture but today we're going to look at
the very exciting pawn gambit this is
the poisoned pawn black is trying to
argue you know you can't just get your
queen out and then just start taking all
my pawns you know you got to develop
your pieces meanwhile black is going to
get very active play he's going to
attack the center you know he's got lots
of pressure here on the center the Queen
is you know very nicely placed sometimes
if I can go here so maybe some good
things will happen for me and really you
put your Queen on g4 so we're going to
go a few more moves we'll get to the
main tabia for this position
rook g8 exactly and have this pawn and
so for the moment black our White has
all of le pawns black has six pawns but
he is about to get one back when he
takes on d4 so after he takes it would
be a big mistake to take here big
mistake yeah Queen c3 so he's going to
get that pawn back and now white needs
to make a decision and it is kind of
funny because it's I've had people ask
me why would you play this with either
side why would white go grab all these
pawns why you know what black give up
pawns you know White has the two bishops
black has active pieces and that's going
to be the the theme you know so black is
he's gonna hope to develop his pieces
he's got some logical squares often this
Bishop will maneuver to another diagonal
very very often he's a he's castling
queenside and he gets a lot of counter
play and we'll see it and a lot of the
times you know either white this is a
huge asset this big past pawn and you
know if I played a game I guess the
master I'll probably show you guys not
you guys I'll probably show the special
for the class that bag game because it
was really quick I played a master all I
did was I pushed my pawn
he didn't stop me so I was funny cuz
he's a master I just push my h-bond and
like wind
yeah very strange game but uh but okay
so sometimes that's that's White's thing
so in end games you know you're a pawn
up and you have this past H Pond so
white would really like to trade Queens
whenever that's possible your n games
are going to favor white because you're
up upon and the King usually will be
stranded here in the center you don't
really want to go Queen side and if we
start pushing our pawns here it's going
to be harder to castle on the Kings side
so very often they can get stuck in the
center so that's part of the
compensation that black gets Ford the
pond so what to do and there's actually
surprisingly two moves here the Queen d3
is not one of them
I assume Queen d3 and I can take either
way I don't know I haven't decided what
I'm take with the most common move by
far is Knight to e2 this defends the c3
square okay it attacks upon that's going
to be useful it does obviously block in
the bishop
you'll probably fianchetto the bishop
sometimes you do sometimes it just stays
there for a while since we're not going
to going to castle anyway and eventually
you know black is going to start putting
stuff in the way and you know that we'll
see how the position will change in
character in just a minute just
sacrifice your rook and Bishop and get a
queen for it what
yeah just do it yeah there's no stopping
it just all the way well that's that's
my my experience they just push it all
the way and you make a queen but okay so
this obviously will come back to this
will show our main feature game here
we'll have the the quote-unquote obvious
move but there also exists this very
unique move King to d1 which is very
surprising but now if you take here it's
obviously not check and okay if you take
there you're going to force this rook to
a file that it usually likes to go to
that rock almost always goes to b1 so
not so bad and the other main reason you
would do this is you're thinking well I
want to develop my knight to a much more
natural square I want to go to f3 so
that's something that you can do in this
line because you're just willing to part
with the c3 pawn and it's kind of like
white is saying well yeah I don't really
care about the material either I'm just
going to put my you can have the pawn
back either now or on the next turn
we'll just put a few moves on the board
and whenever you take it you can have
the pawn back but I also want to just
put my pieces on all the best squares
and the main line here is kind of
surprising there's actually there's a
couple moves that have been played but
the most popular is Knight to g5 all I
need to attack you with is a queen and a
knight that's all I need so we have some
obvious threats and okay there's there's
a couple different ways that you can
play rook f8 and so this is again going
to be central to our theme we really
want to just keep all of our pieces on
the best squares possible this is really
the you know I said a great file for the
rook nice and open we don't want to put
a rook here not if we don't have to and
you don't have to Knight takes e5 which
at first you know my leg good or maybe
maybe looks a little risky f4 absolutely
Bishop f4
so if Bishop f4 so I always have the
opportunity to sack the exchange I
assume I can also play f6 which is the
main line after f4 for some reason most
people sacrifice the exchange here which
is interesting but it isn't necessary
but it does keep kind of with the theme
of the the opening but it is a nice rook
so perhaps even a little bit better is
the move f6 there's not a whole lot of
games that have gone this way but either
move should be a decent position for
black but since most people don't play
that we won't spend too much more time
on it in this position
almost everybody universally plays
Knight to e2 ok and we can take here now
we can take here in a minute there's
lots of transpositions
so we will look at just the main move
here you know develop your knight attack
pawns defend this thing you know and
you'll notice too there's a trick so
this is not a threat because Knight
takes exactly so this was this was not a
threat and if you take you really
shouldn't I go here so since he's not
threatening that we can safely develop
our knight and now it is really time for
him to defend his e pawn so f4 and now
we can take and we'll look at this will
this would be sort of a main line that
we'll look at via transposition so the
most common moves here is either you
take the pawn or you play Bishop d7 and
I want to go over this line because it's
becoming more popular it's sort of the
new modern main line for this opening
the old way they play they'd always play
with Bishop d7 but this but this does
have some independent significance and
we'll look at that so after here again
the most popular line has been Bishop to
d7 we'll have a look at that but
becoming trendy R is this move d4
so we're going to lose a pond and this
is how we choose Wesley so that's his
name this is how we choose to lose our
pond and so we'll take a look at this in
a second and try to understand I mean
what kind of move is d4 we'll have a
look but let's just for a second go
ahead and look at the main main line so
this is how most games have been played
and there's lots of moves the two most
common obviously being taking the pawn
you can take with the knight or the
queen taking what the Queen does have
the benefit of keeping this knight
pinned and even if we castled we never
really want to trade Queens so that can
be slightly annoying white wants to
trade to Queens because he's a pawn up
and he has the past H pawn so he's
almost winning if he gets to trade the
Queens and enter an endgame
so black does have to be really careful
black wants to keep the pieces on the
board I mean especially the Queen's
because this King is not going to be as
safe as the black King you can imagine
you know we castle and then we go to b8
it's a lot safer than this King is going
to end up being especially whenever
white starts pushing his pawns so yes
it's a it's definitely black it wants to
keep the stuff on the board we look at
this move which is the most popular move
gets out of the way of the bishop and it
does immediately sort of threaten to go
here gained a tempo and then plop the
knight in yeah oh well let me draw my
arrow plop the knight into D six which
would be rather devastating so to move a
six okay make sense say I have to stop
your threat and this sets up a very
sneaky trap rook to b1 you know just
seems like okay just a good move that's
where the rook usually goes no big
problem but there's actually a little
trap here we can castle long no why not
oh that was easy
all right Queen takes a six this is
indeed the the trap in then so okay if
you take you're in a lot of trouble and
if you don't take you're in a lot of
trouble so you get a position like this
which
is not very pleasant for the the second
player here only down three pawns is
that you said no big deal yeah no big
deal three pawns in an endgame yes so
obviously this is the super dream
endgame for for white yeah exactly
okay so that is a little trap so okay
the main line here instead Knight a5
which does defend the b7 square so on
some lines when you try to sacrifice
okay I can drop my knight back and also
maybe more importantly I can block this
diagonal I can just plop my knight in to
c4 and all of your your tricks will be
thwarted
so h4 very typical move and black really
has to decide where the best squares for
all of his pieces are now having seen
this weakness and I mean you look at
White's position there really are a lot
of weaknesses so he does have to kind of
work hard to maintain all of his pawns
because black does get quite a lot of
compensation for the pawn first we go
here before we play your move we want to
jump in here if you'll let me
so I should stop this elevator what's an
elevator
rogue h3 it's an elevator I like that
yeah so white does an elevator the rook
lifts up
yeah protects the the g3 square and okay
we Castle and just to give you sort of
an idea of where all the pieces go black
will in the future he'll play here
sometimes what is nice not hanging
you'll be able to push and this Bishop
will have a great diagonal the white
should double up on the H file
maybe so this is the main line and this
is sort of the position you know it's
obviously very sharp very double-edged
and that's why you would play this
position as black you're really trying
to win this is a great opening for
trying to win you know whether you're
playing a lower or higher rated player
this is an opening that very often leads
to a decisive result so we'll go back
that
the main mainline but we will return
here to the the main main position main
main main exactly how many three or four
do you believe it no okay fair enough
and we're going to be following a game
that was played in 2014 at the kappa
blanka memorial this is the game between
all masse so Zoltan L Massey vs. Wesley
so who's playing in the tournament right
now and Wesley was playing with the
black pieces and it's a very good
illustration of how to play this opening
what he does it's it's very nice he
maneuvers all of his pieces to all the
best squares that's exactly how you play
this position as black and a very
phenomenal demonstration of what to do
and very lately you know this this move
d4 is becoming more and more popular so
we'll go ahead and check it out now the
most popular move is the obvious move
Knight takes pawn so we'll look at that
and then we'll come back to the game
continuation where I played the
alternative which is Knight to g3 so we
will come back to this move I'll just
speak about it for a minute it is very
logical Black's last move undefended
some light squares let's make them green
for fun some light squares and so the
knight is thinking alright I'll just
jump in here I'll jump into some of
these squares that's the weakness of the
last move or maybe I'll just keep my
knight there and there's so many games
where white has trouble castling and
just having a safe King that maybe I'll
play Bishop e2 and I'll Castle so those
are the possibilities for white which
makes this move rather decent try and
also at the top level when Wesley so
plays this you know and you're a
grandmaster
he's like 2650 at the time of this game
2693 at the time of this game you know
it's it's you do you really want to go
into his prep he's obviously studied the
main main line so trying to go for a
small tangent small little side line
makes a lot of sense but just to see
let's go down the main line here of this
you know with the when black plays d4
okay we take and they take back and you
do have to be really careful here why'd
you play Bishop d7 you're right but
why'd you do it okay in this obvious
this is yes you can CAC so long you can
put your Bishop here on c6 the correct
square for the bishop you can run into
trouble if for example you just attack
this Queen just weakening the King which
one the black King you can get into
trouble with a move like this if you go
to a dark square I'll have some sort of
check that will annoy you and if we get
to do this and I can take either way
again this is going to be an ink game
that's really going to favor white you
know he's going to be able to protect
his pawn and he's just coming up a pawn
in a in an endgame
yep upon right four six three five yeah
he's up upon so this is the sort of
endgame the white really wants to get
into where you know he's just up upon
you do have to be careful which is why
Bishop to d7 is in fact the move okay
and the white rook relieves the bishop
of his duty of defending the Jeep on
maybe in the future I'll play g4 and
maybe I just want to get my bishop out
to some good square why does he play g4
win why in the future because I'm you
know I want to play here and I want to
play here and I want to bust you open
and I want to make passed pawns you know
I got to got passed pawn I want to go
make a queen so I'm obviously going to
play with my pawns on this side of the
board because that's where I'm gonna
it's rife a pastor and that's where I'm
going to make a queen in the future in
the endgame I'm going to make a queen
over on this side of the board you have
a question you're rubbing your eyes okay
okay now we can attack the Queen because
the check is gone and you do have to be
careful here as white if you just make a
careless move the Queen is coming to
this diagonal and then next the bishops
coming in you know the rooks coming over
so you can actually what I can get a
super initiative
the Queen does want to stay on this
diagonal this is a loose piece after all
you know if you move away and you don't
want that to become a target for the
Queen here yeah I'm black did trade off
the dark squared bishop early which is
usually not only a good attacker it's a
good defender but but it is truly a good
attacker but this guy actually usually
becomes a very powerful piece this is
the French Bishop usually it's terrible
but in the winter where if you can get
control of the bishops this actually is
an exchange that is good for black well
the sound is off so Ben Simon is
somewhere he's like I'll land to make
the sound for a legal move but this is
actually a very powerful piece and if
you can get control of the light squares
usually around the King there's a lot of
weaknesses especially maybe for your
knight you might get a good night versus
a bad Bishop and the knight might be
able to be on some safe light square in
the future okay so we go back and hear a
very interesting maneuver come in just
come in what are you doing where are you
going where's that guy going okay all
right um okay Bishop d3 and now we'll
see this maneuver with the Queen very
interesting the Queen just grabs a very
nice outpost she's actually quite
annoying she's going a lot of different
directions here and I'll put the ship
here next and this also occurs quite
frequently and we'll see it in our main
game so this is always the big question
and in general this is a mistake for
white to make so you do compromise the
pawn structure but it's it's not really
about that for black it's all about just
having pieces on good squares and now
maybe this Bishop will go grab a nice
square right in the middle of the board
and you have a dark squared Bishop so
it's gonna be hard to remove maybe I'll
go here white doesn't want to give away
the light squared bishop in this type of
position and what black is obviously
just seeking very active play and
now there's no counterpart to this so in
general this is a mistake by wife okay
so the main move is is indeed would be
one very sensible
what if Queen a two then I'll take it
I wasn't bluffing okay so the main line
we put you put the bishop on the most
logical diagonal and you go after the
pond so now I wonder what the class
would do in this position D four looks
nice for the night okay
then maybe this is okay probably fun yes
Arjun
rook da so you don't want to castle you
want to play Rock d8 okay well I do
wanna play right da why do you not want
to castle I guess when you want your
king on EA not here people are really
afraid of this pin but out you play king
b8 don't you want your king over here
this is the safest spot for your your
king over here you want to go to b8
which is why the main move here is to
castle
and again you know we don't want to go
through some weird distortion to try to
keep our pawn that's not what it's about
just put your pieces on the most active
squares get dynamic compensation so and
after the capture so now we're down to
ponds but we've very nice pieces all of
our pieces have achieved a very
harmonious setup they're all in very
nice squares okay we get out of the pin
so the audience can woo not pinned and
we'll just go a little bit farther at
some this is not the only way but this
has been played and this has even been
played by Caruana as black so you know
good people are playing this way and so
the games won like this this was another
game and you can notice they got this
position and it will just we'll just
stop here and okay what is really tied
up you're down to pawns and almost every
single top-level game here has just been
a draw so the fact that white has
material is you know it's about it's
about enough to compensate for the fact
that you have really really active
pieces is black and it's sort of a
matter of taste some people you know
they're really greedy they like that to
be up the pawns and some people like to
really active pieces you know that it's
much easier to play and you know
especially in a tournament game it's
just really easy to play the game when
all of your pieces are just beautifully
in harmony so that is the main way that
these games have gone
so after d4 but we'll return now to the
Wesley so game and
to move Knight to g3 again possibly with
the intentions of jumping in here
possibly with the intention of just
getting on with castling and having a
safe King 57 we got to get on with
castling and okay so the obvious plan
for this Bishop is the same we want to
get it over on this diagonal in the
future so was they will need to read
maneuver his pieces we'll see that in a
second
and his opponent played here which has
been played successfully by Kuryakin
twice cariocans won two games with this
as white never lost with it so it's it
is a very serious response but I guess
let's answer the question what if we
just jump right in you know we'll just
we'll just come right in so again if we
remember the theme of the lecture I'd
like to ask the audience well what would
you guys do in this position castles
excellent so obviously this lets us get
for it and we have to move over and we
we lose a pond but what matters is not
the pond it's about putting your pieces
on the best square now your king is on
the best square so fantastic and before
taking he can take now where you can
throw in this move to provoke a weakness
so it's a little more accurate and after
they take you can play here so this is a
very common way to play this yeah so the
knight goes back okay we'll just look at
this line briefly so again you can kind
of see that black is going to put all
his pieces on all these great squares
you know then I can come in here are the
white squares gonna be weak for for
white for black it is double-edged you
know so it can backfire the white
squares can be weak you know I you know
this Queen might be able to come in here
this pawn might be able to go here in
the future so both Kings really do have
to be sort of careful it is that's how
the nature of the position and that's
what you're playing for is black you're
playing a position that you could very
easily move lose with you know one wrong
move but it's the same for white
and I'll show you this game so this was
a game that was played in 2010 Kovas
Avik vs boo call so as a 2594 player
versus a 2390 player and in this game
there was already a fantastic move
played in this position so you may want
to pause your video or you may want to
i'll give the audience just a minute
here sack the night okay I'll give you
guys like one second
sack the night this is a powerful
sacrifice that needs to be calculated in
several lines you are trying to bust
open the center when you play this way
as black you really want to go get this
exposed King and taking the two central
pawns away this is quite useful but now
he played a very accurate move the next
two moves are also very nice not only
did he sack is night but the follow-up
is very pretty as well what you say
Bishop c6 excellent which is much
stronger than the check as we'll see on
this next move take what the pond
take the queen with what should I take
the Queen with you know I don't you want
to take care he played a a much prettier
move yeah this should be for and in the
game he saw nothing better than taking
and then rook takes e5 so this was
played but it's not the end of the story
but after they achieve this position
it's very unusual in balance so if
obviously blacks future plans are to be
able to manufacture this move you know
probably with the help of the Queen if
he ever gets to play d3 under the right
conditions he's gonna be looking good
which which I do like
waiter black why do you like black
mm-hmm yeah efore and d3 which is coming
and here already a blunder but not an
easy one to punish and it wasn't
punished in the game so you can pause at
home I'll give it away because it's a
very difficult move and I want to get on
with things here here in the game Queen
h7 and then okay this this was like okay
this is okay but he could have won you
won a lot faster with the move rook to
f8 the idea is to prevent the move rook
to f2 really you don't believe it
if rook f2 you can take bring the Queen
over and fork these pumps okay so that
would be bad news for white so this is
you know the computer found this to one
second and it's like you know minus
three blacks totally winning now in it
for example the computer continuation
you know you can attack my queen you can
check me but on my next move I played e3
and black wins we won't add Aloka like
too deep it's just that's a nice game
and it illustrates the sort of tactical
ideas that you're looking for you know
you want to be very tactically alert
when you play this as black I mean
you're down material so you are kind of
looking for tactics to justify a lot of
your moves and the sacrifice on e5 is
just a very common theme that you'll see
in a lot of win or games okay but going
back is opponent very mature I'll just
play Bishop e2 you know maybe I'll
cancel maybe I'll get my bishop to this
nice diagonal and okay in the game he
castled there like every what we're back
to the Wesley so game a lot of sources
there's like lots of books that give
this move the idea is just to prevent
rook be one for the for the moment so
this is a very interesting line to
explore but the most popular move has
been to castle it was Wesley's choice so
I could play rook b1 here and again the
same idea is possible if black wants to
play that way but okay from this
position onward let's see if we can
maneuver our pieces like Wesley so and
this is this is sort of a nice test how
would you guys Riemann over your pieces
so this is a planning exercise what's
the plan how do you put all of your
pieces on the best squares and I'll give
you a minute you can pause at home you
can run away whatever you want to do you
can whisper cheep
maybe nine to five right away
Leslie liked that idea
negative five right away
and the plan is we we sort of we sort of
got it he's gonna put his other night on
e seven okay it's going to go to d5 and
the bishop will assume a very powerful
diagonal where you know it's eying down
on some squares here what if he just
takes since the question and he did not
take and so again we see this similar
pawn structure and again it's one that
white really doesn't mind too much now
maybe the bishop will reach this
diagonal the a different route maybe
we'll put our knight here and one of our
pieces will go to c4 which can be kind
of annoying and this is really the pawn
structure that black doesn't mind when
he plays this variation and so he said
okay do it you know take that's fine
with me but his opponent said nope I
want to jump in to some of these squares
and I assume why it was thinking about
blacks plan and he found a way to stop
him from doing it after the knight
retreats he gets to play Knight f6
gaining a tempo on the rook and after
the rook moves he just takes the French
Bishop and so on a lot of French lines
this would you know just be like crazy
why would you go take that bad bishop
but with this diagonal opened up it's
actually a very very powerful piece and
white wants to control the light squares
in this position so wisely took back
okay fair enough
now since the pros after this move let's
say they made a couple tidying up moves
and here in a second
okay the knight goes where we said it
would go as pointed out maybe III was it
is a good future home for these Knights
and now just rook b1 putting the piece
on the better square and as we've seen
the King goes to be eight which is
usually the right square for the king
okay now this move this should be four
as Wesley overlooked something is it
looks like weight is just going to win
upon what's going on here
night which night yeah so the problem
with jumping in is the that rook takes
here and you lose material so okay I
mean it appears that I see plundered you
noticed 2700 almost 2,800 as he as he
really blundered here well in the game
struck back and white did not take and
so again he's going to tactically
justify you not being able to take this
pawn and this is sort of what happens
when you have the more active pieces in
the game to move a four but if you just
grab this and okay you go ahead and
let's just say white really helps
himself he's like great extra pond I'm
the best he actually runs into some
trouble and so things work out well for
you when your pieces are on good squares
and here's a really good example in this
position black can play here okay before
King the pieces you know your queen in
your rook so you're going to take me
right okay
pawn takes
Queen c6 exactly so we get onto this
diagonal so it's kind of cool the Queen
sort of doing what the bishop did that's
a very nice diagonal for us in this
opening and we're preventing you if we
just take right away well your queen is
going to go to e4 so we can gain a tempo
by attacking the Jeep on and now we take
this is a very annoying pond and this
rook is going here and we're going to
make some threats so this actually can
very quickly backfire on white okay and
very alert you know as a opponent
probably worked it out because I hold it
not going to take it I'm going to play a
four and this is a very common theme for
white where's this bishop going over
here
nobody knows well maybe yeah right so
he's not going this way he's going to go
to a3 this is I mean so this is a very
very typical move that white will play
you know we got to push the pawn so that
the bishop gets this really nice
diagonal you know maybe I'll get to take
here and maybe I'll get to put my my
bishop on d6 and force you to give up an
exchange and okay it's just a nice
diagonal in general so that's where I'm
going okay what this wasn't going to do
all right it is it's going to scare the
audience if I remember right so so be
it's going to be okay though
it's all gonna be okay he entered into a
pinned but it's going to be okay alright
we're gonna we're gonna get through this
one right we're gonna die but the other
variation you like you I got we're
pinned the audience couldn't stand it
but okay this self pinning he's not
going to move this night very soon I'm
attacking your pawn so uh Queen a four
if white doesn't make a move take the
pawn and so the deal is the same you
know so if you take here still the same
deal I'll jump this in and before I take
back I'll go here
so it's still the same thing all of
these these turns later but okay here's
the point
a 6 B 6 okay Luke wants B 6 will play v6
okay that's what Wesley said um and now
what did he play here I think I remember
after work to b3 something is going to
go here broke a bishop something's going
to go to a3 how to make more progress
here as black all right now's the time
let's jump in and oh it's actually very
interesting at this specific moment this
is actually a very strong move so if
here we have this pin which is actually
a little bit annoying and
mm-hmm yeah so how are you how are you
going to get back there and defend that
bishop mm-hmm but there's also another
super computer line in this variation if
rook e1 which also seems sensible you
know so now this there's no pin you know
it's not it's not a serious pin at least
but there's a super duper computer line
and it would have been very nice to see
if Wesley would have solved it at his
opponent fall for this so a very nice
way to win would have been this
sacrifice but why does this work okay
he takes yeah 93 night h4 okay so I have
to defend my bishop yeah if Queen a1 I
assume I can drop my queen back but what
if I attack a pin to peace again okay
you go defend it again and this is what
the computer is good at watch watch some
of these maneuvers okay
take mine and I take your rook all right
protect okay I attack the piece again
all right you go back is it a draw and
if this move works then you're in
trouble because now you trade a lot of
stuff and pick up the rook so very very
computer line it would have been
exciting to see what Wesley have found
that that continuation so there there
are definitely some tactical problems
and obviously tactics again they you
know they're going to favor whoever has
the better position whoever has the
better pieces you know even if your
opponent has a pawn or two extra having
the better pieces will mean usually the
tactics are going to work out in your
favor so instead rokay three all right
I'll just keep going like this and if
this were a Dany Machuca lecture we
would just repeat forever
he taught he probably made me promise
that I wouldn't tell you what he was
going to lecture on tonight but it was
it was unspectacular okay so he doesn't
want to repeat
okay he's playing to win and uh okay
kind of forced so I asked you how would
you take back in this position upon
takes followed by Rick T two very
interesting so again in the game that's
exactly what he did I mean take moving
the night in here is probably fine for
for both players I don't know I assume I
would play move like this or something
sometimes you have to worry about
sacrifices and I'm coming in and getting
you but it looks very holdable for white
I don't I don't think there's any major
problems if you have a question can you
just raise your hand but he took with
the pawn again he doesn't mind the
material loss that's not what he's
interested in he's interested in
improving his pieces and in this case
he's talking about his pawns as well
II - this pawn is very dangerous you
have to move your rope and rook d1 but I
ask you what's the threat again there's
the small tactical threat the white
needs to be white needs to be alert when
your opponent's pieces are this good you
got to be careful there might be some
tactics Queen c5 check how do I do you
know that I can do an old move but okay
Queen c5 check Queen takes
the rook takes rook and I go here and
you're making a queen okay
also if you check me I supposed to I can
move that's my alternative and I can't
move what do I do
how do I pass let's just pass and so the
suggestion sorry one more time was a if
it were blacks turn so will let's just
pass not a good move at all I don't know
a better way to pass but at this check
so if you check okay I'm going to take
and it was this was the idea I'll go
here and okay so even if you're checking
me I just take your pawn if you know you
take my queen I get to take your rook
and this this is good for white so it
doesn't quite work that's not after a
working one that's not the big threat in
the position but it does have to do with
the fact yeah we're very alert we know
this you know this is a guy that maybe
we want to take so he was trying to
remove the Queen which is exactly the
idea so yeah so the big threat is
obviously a rook to c8 removing the
Queen from the defense of the rope so
very alert to this he grabbed this night
and now this move anyway and here is is
very interesting white is in a lot of
Jeopardy here and so I assume he had
this in mind in maybe overlooked that
just how strong Wesley's position is but
there's a very brilliant way that white
can actually save this game and not just
totally crumble and it's a very tricky
move so I mean pause this is a great
great puzzle that move that that could
have been played here is a really genius
move
in the game he played queen g3 which
seems like the obvious that's why I took
your night so I could play Queen g3 but
okay the super the super duper genius
move I hope you took a time at home is a
again it's White's turn to not really
care about material we we're gonna have
to abandon this rook for a minute and
play the ultra brilliant Queen III
setting up some threats of his own if
you take you should take I mean take the
rook okay if you the best move here is
Queen d8 which not only defends g6 but
tactically protects the rook because if
you take a check and check and your King
moves away and then I queen with check
so this is actually the best move but if
let's just play a dummy move rook a one
just to see the threat its mate
which takes b6 and then you only
calculated this and si you saw the mate
so here this is the the easy line Bishop
back and you're going to get mated you
can block with your work in your queen
but you're getting may do so and even if
you think you're clever it's not clever
enough because after this check and
there's one more check your you don't
really have any good moves here you this
is like a perpetual you still agree with
that
how about losing it looks it looks like
losing this one losing looks like so
okay that I mean what it what an amazing
move had you found it queen III and okay
with with best play let's we can show
the computer line its computer said you
go here the rook goes anywhere doesn't
really matter you take and then black
can take his choice of pawns and Lex
still a little bit better you know but
I'm defending against your sack and why
does not just totally lost the game but
okay how are we going to punish this
move let's go back in time a second I
took and uh Queen g3 how is he going to
punish this well okay let's get our
clean a little more active you know
force you you can just go away I never
want you to be able to come up here and
you know protect your palm and your
broken and stuff so I'll just just go
away a little bit and there's a lot of
good moves but it takes the bishop it's
good
and now after the route goes back a very
professional move I mean taking here and
then taking on c2 winds rather easily
but very professional guards against any
possible counterplay the white may ever
hope to achieve this is again that's the
diagonal the Queen has wanted to go to
you know just like you want a bishop or
Queen on that diagonal it's it's such a
monster piece and oK we've defended our
rook again there's there's no counter
play at all you have to make lifts here
because we're threatening to take this
and drop our Queen in okay so we just
triple up and just now you've you've
broken this pin so it's not it's not
very good okay Queenie for just to prove
your position and now it's just really a
technical win from here so nothing that
is is too difficult for a twenty seven
hundred player at this point but white
did try a little something he gets he
gets some checks in here in a second so
you played here okay you take with a
queen i play rook d1 so okay he plays a
clever move okay my last hope this is it
in it at first maybe looks good
especially when you you see this move
because I mean I have to block with my
queen
so okay that looks looks pretty good for
white but if I can escape the checks I
just move my rook away and then I Queen
and then I win so he got checked a
little bit but nothing major just run
away and okay just keep keep attacking
me I move my broke out of the way my
queen and here the game ended so - Amon
allow you can see every move he just
kept putting his pieces on better and
better squares until the tactics just
really worked out in his favor his
opponent was put under a lot of pressure
for the whole game and you know despite
White's
material advantage just the constant
pressure is the sort of thing they're
playing and that's why
you you want to play the winner where as
black it's a very fighting aggressive
opening that'll have to do for our
coverage on the the widower
you